[Musique]
donc c'est vraiment en première un dévot
sinda et ça c'est ton premier non non
c'est pas ton premier cépage et papoter
30 40
[Musique]
je veux partir en vacances avec moi tu
la connais depuis quand même temps puis
ce week-end mais un truc bizarre pas
exactement la même source ont chaque
fois très flippant en bulgarie
et pourquoi la bulgarie tu as oublié ce
que c'était que les vacances en couple
[Musique]
mais c'est très long et il ya plein de
trucs ou y est là
cette annonce beach le truc la france
est un band vino avec des pommes de
terre c'est délicieux
non non non je suis en train de prendre
ses marques sur un rameur la crise y est
là non les vacances ce mini moke déjà un
peu de sable propre au quai et une eau
qui ressemblent pas du coq à moi ce que
j'aime chez les français c'est que vous
êtes toujours habite aventure je peux
visiter les toilettes avec le foulard tu
vois ça ça veut dire s'occuper scénario
bonnes vacances
je suis pour les inspire parions j'ai
passé la justice
m
c'est quoi le canyoning memories au
peuple
est marion faut arrêter de trouver tous
bien dans la vie
on sent à emmaüs au lit c'est officiel
on est au paradis
y a que du mar
[Musique]
après god bless you hold up your wife
hicham hommes armés alors oui de
chirurgie ou comme tel engin les
vacances c'est la pire épreuve du couple
normes commencer par là
[Musique]